it is the farming state where Trump
triumphed but we're now across these
fields what's growing is dissatisfaction
so here's a plant I'll I'll pull one up
for you so you can have a better look
the soybean farmers of Iowa are on the
front line of the trade war and they're
hurting the Chinese have chosen to
target soybeans and we're soybean
farmers it's one of the most important
crops in the state so it's it's
definitely right in the crosshairs Dave
Walton voted Trump in 2016 but now he
says he'll see how the tariffs play out
before deciding where his next vote goes
there are farmers on all ends of the
spectrum you know there are people that
are really upset with the way that the
the trade war is happening there's
others that know that we needed to do
something about trade and it is big
business here whether by barge along the
Great Mississippi or on long trains
across it every day the crop is carted
to ports for shipment to China a
precious lucrative market now under
threat and awkwardly for Trump the
elections loom here the midterms will be
the first real referendum on Donald
Trump's presidency and his trade war may
well exact a political price here in
Iowa a swing state where the tariffs are
biting and the Democrats are fighting
hard it's a new look Democrat Party here
young female from a blue-collar family
and strong on workers rights
[Music]
and yet on these hot summer nights in
Iowa where they pamper their cars and
ponder their politics Democrat
supporters are hard to find
I think the economy's doing very well it
is and that is what matters yes and I
think that's what's important to people
in the United States you know there's
tariffs things he employed I think
that's a good thing you think that's
gonna bring jobs back to the United
States so and I think this fair trade
thing I don't think it's been very there
fair for years and years I think the
other countries have been kind of taking
advantage of this
they backed Trump then they back him
still these like many across this land
believe the president is on their side
well he does what he says he need I just
don't talked he does things I like the
fact that he's not a typical politician
he doesn't he's a business person and so
he's trying to run it like a business
and that makes sense to me
[Music]
at rallies Trump puts his faith in the
resilience of farmers to ride out his
trade war you know what our farmers are
saying it's ok we can take it these are
incredible people we can take it we need
to support him we need to show strength
to our trading partners and and by
undermining them it shows it shows
weakness Dora train trading partners and
I don't think that's a good idea right
now but in the soybean fields of this
state patience is not unlimited and they
know that ultimately they have that
all-important vote in their hands Mark
Austin Sky News Iowa
[Applause]